to orlando where before the portland
trailblazers came out onto the floor
this afternoon
they all huddled up and around their
teammate yusuf nurkic whose grandmother
hannah
passed away earlier today and before
coach terry starts his pregame speech
i'm told there was a moment of silence
for nurture's grandma nurtures told
reporters on july 31st
after the blazer's first seating game
that he had considered leaving the
bubble because his grandmother was back
in bosnia
and battling covid19 terry stotz told us
then
that he could tell that it was really
weighing on nurkic
and that he was in constant phone
communication with family back at home
part of the reason nurkin said he wanted
people to know that his grandmother was
sick
was so that they could take this virus
seriously he was urging people
wear a mask unfortunately nerk's
grandmother has now become another
victim
of this pandemic mike thank you lisa so
many
sad stories there and and
it's not easy to do that to talk about
that publicly but to get that message
out which clearly you know hit him
directly with his family
is so important
[Applause]
there you see damian lillard they have a
they have a
terrific relationship those two lillard
said that nurkic
just love the energy that they're
playing with competing on the defensive
side of the ball
lillard seeing two players nurkic
for three that's good yusuf nurkic from
downtown
take the double team and make the play
puts nerk in position to make a play
whether it be
passing it or the wide open through
keeps it alive
nurkic and valentina's battling pretty
spin move
nurkic for three that's his second
three-pointer knickers now
nine points eleven rebounds and portland
back up by four
gang of gang defending nurkic on the
perimeter he's got to give him space
this guy's more than qualified cross
court passive danger
making her proud i mean it's a tough day
for him but
he has certainly shown up for his
teammates in this
the organization
[Music]
lillard gets free back up top gabriel
inside nurkic
quick turn and bucket
[Applause]
six point portland lead as we approach
two minutes remaining in the second
littler nice feed inside perfect timing
and nurkits throws it down
midway through the third we're all even
lillard to nurkic
nurkic rattles it home he didn't want to
shoot it at first but he was left wide
open
cj mccollum so they try to set a screen
and get him off of him
mccullum kicks it out anthony for three
rebound nurkic banks at home and a foul
and portland has regained the lead
and then step back knocks down the jump
shot how about this big guy
nurkish he's been outstanding for both
of you guys how much of this was for
nurkic
playing with a heavy heart yeah all of
it honestly
i can't even fathom what he's going
through you know having lost some people
in my family
you know it's something you never get
over something you just try to get
through so we're just trying to support
them and
understanding that this is a very
difficult time for him and his family
first questions coming from casey hold
on with trailblazers.com
first off use of condolences man uh
really
really
sorry to hear the news um she's talking
about your decision to play today your
your thoughts and feelings coming into
this one
uh knowing that you just got the news
basically right before the game
the first one thank you i don't have
much to say about it
i think i didn't want to play i think
she made me play
i guess uh personally i thought
i'm not gonna play tonight but just
be in the locker room they don't want to
get shooting ball out there warm-ups and
stuff but i think
um i already came did all those
decisions to stay here
and be with the team so mine's all i
think she wanted to play so
i'm glad we win and i'm winning the
playoffs what we came for
next question is coming from dwight
james with nbc sports northwest
looking ahead to the lakers
what kind of a challenge is it for you
they have davis now you haven't played
against them
uh with the players they have now uh are
you excited about a chance to play
against them
i don't care about none of them man we
have a team
we just care about ourselves man you
know
they are a great team and but they gotta
earn it so
i don't think we you know we are 18
necessarily
but i don't care about lakers i care
about my team and how we can prepare to
play the first game then
next question is coming from jared
greenberg with turner sports
you said sorry for your loss um i know
this has been a difficult time for you
have you considered going home or will
you stay here
i decided
[Music]
i'm not sure